i would say because you don't have a
normal life you didn't go to high school
you need to
the idea that you date and the
relationships don't go on forever i
think is a good thing
that you and jacob broke up me too i
think it's a i think it's a great thing
i think that
i also think it's a good thing that we
we dated in the first place i think that
you know
i've learned from that would you ever
date another actor again on uh let you
meet in a movie
no i i i couldn't i i
not not no this is absolutely no like
dig at actors because
actors are my favorite people in the
world i i like my favorite
um this is just for me like i think that
it's awesome to date somebody who's in
your field who gets it
but doing the same exact thing as
somebody is tough it's really tough
because it's competitive you're not
thinking i'm competing with this person
ever what you're thinking is i hope that
this
this success that either of us is having
and you're thinking mostly about
yourself and the way you're like i hope
that this
opportunity that i'm getting is not
hurting their feelings
i am so glad you just said that because
it's honest
yeah you don't want to be sitting there
going oh [ __ ] i'm doing so well he must
feel bad
i mean and that's what happens certain
people though honestly
like i will say i know a lot of actors
who are with actors who are married to
actors like
and it it works amazing and it really
and i'm like wow that's
freaking awesome but i've dated a few
actors before i've never viewed my
relationship with them as like
oh i'm not happy for them i only want
success but i was worried and i'm sure
they were as well like oh will they be
happy for me
and you're you're creating a problem
that's not even there when you're just
thinking that so
no offense to jacob in this situation
but you're the star he's doing great and
he's
doing fine he's got his show and he's
doing wonderfully
yeah but there's he's great on that show
there's no way for him sitting in a
relationship with you
during the the accolades you're getting
for the act for
the success of the kissing booth and
sitting there and going oh
[ __ ] she's doing so well i don't think
that there's any reason
for people to compare us like they do
all the time
um because we're completely like you
know we dated for a minute
and now we're completely separate people
with completely separate careers but it
has to be awkward as hell when you make
kissing booth two and three and he's in
it
it's the coolest part of my job you know
to be able to
i think um do something that
isn't easy you know i mean i would say
that
regardless of the experience elle evans
always needs her noah flynn is how i'd
like to put it and i think that
no matter the circumstances i was
willing to
have that experience happen because you
can't have an l without a noah you know